nike dunk  tongue  jordan four  [Music]  laces  this is off white  got ridges  the presto  no  you got ridges on it  this is lebron  kyrie  giannis  chris paul  bro what the freak are these  adidas  uh yeezy um quantum yes  this is a easy quantum  air jordan 4.  air force one  air max  nike swoosh here  and here  um air force two  what the  [ __ ] is this  the house shoe so what did y'all bring  here what is this okay it's perforated  holes on the toe box it's a swoosh right  here  the back has to say nike embroidered  right here that is an air force one  the bottom even is the air force one  bottom  it's a low-cut shoe  i'm sorry i'm sorry  i don't know  i don't know i'm sorry dunk dunk a nike  dunk thank god bro okay